ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States accompanied by the
vice president of the United States
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody
please thank you you definitely have
plenty of distancing I've never seen
distancing like that that's really
that's really very impressive and
welcome to the Rose Garden as we take
powerful action to lower health care
costs for America's seniors today I'm
proud to announce that we have reached a
breakthrough agreement to dramatically
slash the out-of-pocket costs of insulin
you know what's happened to insulin over
the years right through the roof
insulin so many people so necessary for
hundreds and thousands of seniors
enrolled in Medicare that's a big deal
participating plans will cap cost at
just $35 a month per type of insulin and
some plans may offer it free so for
everybody that was getting ripped off
and paying tremendous prices senior
citizens and seem I want to thank you
because you brought this to my attention
a long time ago and you worked very hard
and this day and the press won't even
cover it but they'll cover things that
are unimportant but this is a big day
for seniors is a tremendous saving and
it allows people that you know if you
don't take insulin I just wrote this
down go blind stroke amputation
kidney failure and other things so we're
getting it out $35 per month and it
would be anywhere from 50 to 150 to over
$200 a month so it's a massive cut and I
guess 60 70 % nobody's seen anything
like this for a long time sleepy joke
into this that I can tell you in fact it
was his problem with Obamacare that
caused part of your problem this will
save impact in Americans an average of
minimum
446 dollars just on insulin costs a year
we're pleased to be joined by Vice
President Mike Pence and Surgeon General
Jerome Adams I also want to thank Seema
again thank you very much for the job
you've done helping achieve the
incredible victory for Medicare patients
nationwide in the past Obamacare
prevented insurance providers from
competing to offer lower costs for
seniors there was no competition there
was no anything and they ran away with
what took place and the seniors were
horribly hurt many people couldn't take
insulin they couldn't even think about
it as a result Medicare beneficiaries
with prescription drug coverage paid an
average of six hundred and seventy five
dollars for a year's supply of insulin
and sometimes as high as $1,500 harmful
laws also meant that seniors often paid
a different amount almost every single
month they had no idea what they were
paying they were billed every month they
were pelled a different amount that it
was a massive amount one in every three
seniors on Medicare has diabetes and
over 3.3 million beneficiaries used at
least one type of insulin over the past
ten years these seniors have seen their
out-of-pocket costs for this life-saving
treatment almost double I don't use
insulin should I be uh I never thought
about it but I know a lot of people are
very very badly affected right
unbelievable
that's why my administration acted
decisively we slashed Obamacare's
crippling requirements and opened up
competition like they've never seen
before they've never seen competition
like this between transparency and all
of the other things we're doing nobody's
ever had a competitive competitive
situation created like we've done it and
the prices you will see very soon
they're going to come tumbling down then
we brought all the parties to the table
insurers manufacturers and other key
players and reach the
agreement to deliver insulin at stable
and drastically lower out-of-pocket
costs for our seniors
I hope the seniors are gonna remember it
because Biden is the one that put us
into the gym because they didn't know
what they were doing they were
incompetent soon nearly half of all
eligible Part D and Medicare Advantage
prescription drug plans will offer this
low-cost option and when you say
low-cost you're really talking local
it's giving seniors the freedom and
choice to pick the plan that's right for
them nothing will ever stop me from
fulfilling my solemn duty to America's
seniors I'll use every power at my
disposal to lower drug prices and my
administration will always protect
Medicare and Social Security and by the
way pre-existing conditions and we got
rid of the individual mandate which is a
disaster the worst part of Obamacare was
the individual mandate when we got rid
of the individual mandate essentially we
got rid of Obamacare if you want to know
the truth you can say that in the truest
form but we get rid of a horrible
horrible condition called the individual
mandate but we'll always protect you on
pre-existing conditions much more so
than the Democrats here with us today is
Bruce Broussard president and ce CEO of
a big powerful health care company
Humana and I'd like that Bruce come up
and say a few words please Bruce thank
you that's a big company you up how
young he is - that's very young to be
running such a big company thank you
very much mr. president thank you Bruce
well we are I speak on behalf of our
50,000 teammates at work at Humana that
we are thankful of being here and
honored the demo that what you are
describing just recently is an example
of the strength of public-private
partnerships and dealing with large
issues such as the affordability of
prescription drugs and insulin is by far
the one that has used the most another
great example of that is the response to
the code
and the crisis and I think about one of
our customers Gwen that just recently we
served that didn't was blind did not
have access to food
no one could support her because no one
was in the vicinity to help her
and in addition didn't have access to a
prescriptions and through a strong
private public partnership we were able
to offer her food and prescriptions
delivered to her home so I want to thank
the administration for continuing to
pick on large issues like this and
bringing in the private enterprise to
assist in that so thank you seaman all
everybody everything you've done so
thank you what did you up you've done to
really an amazing job and thank you
you're also in the right business right
well if we can help any senior we're
always in the right that's good that's
good you've really helped that we
appreciate it very much thank you Bruce
we're also joined by Tracy brown the CEO
of American Diabetes Association and a
lot of bad things can happen without
insulin in terms of diabetes and other
things please Tracy thank you very much
Thank You mr. president
Thank You administrator Verma for making
this afternoon one that we can focus on
the 34 million Americans like myself
who's living with diabetes 7 million of
which need insulin to live 25 percent of
these individuals have told us that they
ration or skip doses of their medicine
because they simply cannot afford it
and so this effort CMI MMI demonstration
project that brings together the
government industry and public health
advocacy from the American Diabetes
Association is the right thing to do and
we're thrilled to take this challenge
head-on today together we are helping
millions of seniors access insulin
affordably this is a very big deal the
American Diabetes Association is the
nation's leading organization that
fights for people living with diabetes
and we are committed to continue to
partner to make sure every American and
especially our seniors have access to
the medicine that they need to live so
thank you mr. president and thank you
administrator Verma so Traci are you
surprised at how much we've gotten the
price down to what extent and to the
level that we brought it down to this is
a very exciting day for people living
with diabetes and so any step to bring
this lower is the good good news we know
that we need to do more but I'm so
confident that together we're going to
be able to help all people living with
diabetes thrive good thank you very much
appreciate rise I'd like to also invite
up David Rick's chairman CEO of Eli
Lilly and Company they're very big in a
very great company please there's
another young guy pleasure to be here
really an honor to be a part of this
announcement to improve the lives of so
many patients who live with diabetes in
our Part D program for several years
Lilly's worked hard to improve insulin
affordability and this has been a
missing piece that's now been filled in
by the great collaboration from our plan
companies like Bruce's who are here
Seema Verma your administration vice
president pans president Trump thank you
for your leadership to make this happen
this is the kind of collaboration that
solves real problems for people with
with serious issues like diabetes today
if you take Lily insulin you will not
pay more than $35 except for in the Part
D program and we're pleased to add this
missing part to that equation so that
starting next year seniors will benefit
from that same savings level just a
little bit more than a dollar a day for
insulin that same spirit of
collaboration is also being applied to
collaboration around kovin 19 and I
think everyone's aware that there's
thousands of scientists working in our
industry along with NIH and other
experts to speed around the clock new
therapies
for patients suffering from kovat 19 and
to arrest and extinguish this pandemic
I've never been more proud to be a part
of that effort as well in the same
spirit of collaboration is being applied
in that incredibly important crisis as
well together by working together I
think we proved today we can solve
long-term problems and I hope I can come
back someday and show that we've solved
the immediate problem of copán 19
working as an industry along with
government so thanks for having me here
we will thank you very much thanks David
appreciate it really good job I also
want to thank the companies with us
today for rising to the occasion in our
fight against the invisible enemy Humana
and other insurers have agreed to waive
co-pays which is a very great thing to
do it's a big it's a big deal thank you
very much coinsurance deductibles
coronavirus treatments for most
enrollees I mean what they did is really
as people that aren't in the business or
even in business period they wouldn't
realize how big a thing that is but it's
a very big thing and we appreciate it
very much
coronavirus treatment for most enrollees
has been we've been moving along and
we're doing well we're gonna be
reporting on it in just a second Santa
Fe is working at breakneck speed to
create a vaccine Eli Lilly has been
developing therapeutics for coronavirus
and expanding a free drive through
testing operations and thank you all for
the work it's been great
we're battling the virus and every front
speeding relief to our work workers and
pursuing therapies and vaccines at
record speed we have many companies
right now I think we can say very far
down the line on vaccines and
therapeutics and cures frankly I think
cures are going to be in there very
shortly Manufacturing vast quality
quantities and medical equipment
supplies all of the different things
that you need we've energized our
military our military is ready
logistically to go out and distribute
whatever it is we come up with and I
think we're going to come up with a lot
I think we're going to have
therapeutic remedies and I think we're
gonna have vaccines very shortly I've
been saying it very shortly I think I'll
be proven correct if I'm not I'm sure
the media will let us know about it
we're safely reopening our country while
aggressively protecting the vulnerable
especially our seniors we're telling our
seniors to stay back a little bit stay
back
let this thing pass we're not only
keeping older Americans safe from the
virus we're also ensuring that they have
the best medical care on earth at a
price that they can afford that's what
happened with insulin nobody can believe
it when they hear the price for the
insulin it's been an amazing difference
in Seamas going to be talking about that
that's not just like a 10% drop or a 5%
drop which by itself would be good
that's a big that's a big drop that's a
really big drop we approved a record
number of generics and reverse the trend
of soaring drug prices for the first
time in over 50 years first time we've
ever had prices go down
average basic Part D premiums dropped
13.5 percent the lowest level in seven
years and we're going down verse
abstention from that level it's going
down very very substantial unless you
have a new administration to which case
it'll go up very substantially that I
can guarantee you they've been doing it
to you for years average Medicare
Advantage premiums have plummeted 28% to
the lowest level in over a decade and
that's despite everything that's been
happening which would normally make
things go up and we'd more then let's
see 1200 more Medicare Advantage plans
today
that we did think of that two years ago
so we have 1200 more Medicare Advantage
plans that we did two years ago that's
something I signed an executive order to
crack down on fraud in Medicare and to
give beneficiary faster access to the
latest medical devices and therapies and
to take all of the fraud money and
finding a lot of it all of that money
that we're finding in fraud or reduce
prices we provided nearly 1 billion
dollars in grants to support home
delivered meals and in-home care for
elderly patients
and disabled people during the pandemic
we expanded telehealth which has really
turned out to be a very hot subject
right people that never thought about it
people didn't like the idea right Tracy
they're loving telehealth it's speedy
and it's a lot less expensive
we expanded telehealth for Medicare
beneficiaries and the number of patients
using it has increased from roughly
11,000 a week to nearly 1.3 million so
we went from 11 thousand people to 1.3
million people a week but very big where
you'll be seeing it price transparency
some people think it's better it's
bigger than health care when you look at
it it's going to be bigger than health
care price transparency it was signed
approximately nine months ago it's going
through the process and it'll be here by
the first of the year so I hope you're
gonna remember me just in case the
unthinkable happens but nobody else
would have gotten it but this
administration price transparency it's a
a tremendous that's gonna cut your costs
tremendously and that literally one of
the biggest people in the field said
Trice parents it's going to be a bigger
thing price transparency bigger than
health care in a true sense the cost of
health care is going to come down very
very substantially we're always working
on pre-existing conditions and saving
your pre-existing conditions and as long
as I'm president you'll always be
protected on pre-existing conditions and
surprise medical billing is something
your people are surprised never in a
positive sense and we've written that
out and that's going to be very quickly
ended so you're not going to be
surprised meaning badly surprised very
negatively surprised it's a big thing
people go in they go for an operation
they end up literally losing all of
their money losing everything over
something that should not happen
surprise medical billing we're using
every tool at our disposal to protect
our nursing homes from out
brakes you saw the disaster of how badly
some of the governor's handled nursing
homes it's a disgrace what they've done
what the governor is what some of the
governor's have done is a disgrace we
provided States more resources to step
up inspections added shipments of
personal protective equipment to all
15,400 Medicaid and Medicare certified
nursing homes and issued a strict new
guideline that every nursing home
resident and staffer be tested
immediately and that all staff be tested
weekly so we're making it very very
tough every day of my administration
we're fighting for our seniors like
never before our seniors are very
special people all of our citizens are
special but our seniors would have to
take care of our seniors our senior
citizens have spent their entire lives
working hard supporting their
communities and families and paying into
the system we will not rest until they
get the kind of care and support that
they have earned and that they deserve
now I'd like to ask vice president Mike
Pence to come up and say a few words
followed by administrative Verma and I
would just like to thank you again for
the great job you've done so we'll have
Mike speak and then you'll speak and
thank you very much go ahead Mike thank
you
Thank You mr. president and and let me
say what a what a privilege it is to be
here with business leaders and activists
who have been standing with you standing
with the White House coronavirus task
force from the very beginning it truly
has been a public-private partnership
that's marshaled not just a
whole-of-government approach but a whole
of America approach and we see that
evident today in this historic step for
America's seniors and let me join the
president in expressing our profound
gratitude to the servant heart that each
one of you have brought and all of your
employees have brought the importance of
today's announcement cannot be
overstated mr. president
as you observed early on we recognized
that the coronavirus represented a
particular threat to seniors with
underlying health conditions and
diabetes being among them and today's
step ensures that as we continue to work
to safely reopen our country we're going
to make sure that our seniors have
access to affordable healthcare to
insulin and treatment to be able to meet
that moment along with us mr. president
we gather today with the news of more
than 98 thousand of our countrymen have
succumbed to the corona virus and their
families are in our prayers and in our
hearts but because of the cooperation
and the compassion of the American
people who have heeded your guidelines
for America who have listened and
continue to listen to state and local
authorities we know that there are tens
of thousands of American families that
have been spared that heartbreak and
loss and we we will express our
gratitude to the American people if
you're incredible cooperation the social
distancing the steps that you have
embraced the way you have been willing
to forfeit aspects of your personal
freedom to put the health of others
first but the good news is mr. president
that because of the steps the American
people have taken heeding your
leadership and the guidance of state and
local officials we're getting there and
we're starting to reopen America as we
speak in a safe and responsible way in
fact mr. president every state in the
nation has now taken at least some steps
to reopen their economies fifty-two
states and territories have opened
retail curbside to go with reduced
capacity 44 states we're glad to note
have opened up elective medical
procedures in hospitals and clinics
around the state 38 states and
territories have reopened personal care
under strict hygiene protocols
37 states have reopened restaurants 34
states have reopened non-essential
businesses and the list goes on and I
think most meaningful to you mr.
president is so far 30 states and
territories have reopened houses of
worship under guidance of reduced
capacity while allowing people to come
back together in fellowship and prayer
this has all been made possible because
of the whole of government a whole of
America approach mr. president that you
initiated when you launched the White
House corona virus task force back in
January and before I stepped down let me
at least share a few encouraging words
that we shared with America's governors
today about the progress that we all
have been making because to continue to
safely reopen we believe it's absolutely
essential that we increase visibility by
expanding testing across the country so
that we can ensure that that we can
identify outbreaks where they occur it's
interesting as you watch the daily
numbers new cases are declining around
the country and even more dramatically
when you realize that a significant
portion of new cases every day are
actually in outbreaks in specific
businesses or as we discuss today in
nursing homes or in meatpacking plants
but I'm proud to report mr. president
because of the partnership that you
forged with commercial laboratories
around the country 14 point 1 million
tests have been performed and I heard
again today from governors across
America how they have been in many cases
exceeding the demand in the testing that
they've made available in fact a
governor phil murphy of of new jersey
and for me that he had promised the
people in New Jersey that he would be
doing 20,000 tests a day but in
partnership with the federal government
as we've been providing testing supplies
and accessing resources he told me that
they actually cleared 30,000 tests a day
in New Jersey and most importantly in
that state where at one point nearly 40%
of those
tested and tested positive for the
corona virus and now the governor of New
Jersey informed us that there less than
5% but they're hardly alone mr.
president 42 states are now testing at
less than 10% positive rate and 20
states are testing at less than 5% a
positive rate the reality is that now
all 50 states with the support that
we've been providing sending swabs and
test tubes and medium on a weekly basis
at your direction now all 50 states have
tested more than 2 percent of their
population giving us a much greater
capacity to identify outbreaks as they
occur and protect our citizens and the
progress in evidence is clear all across
America we see hospitalizations
continuing to decline new
hospitalizations have declined steadily
in the chart that you see before you
from April until today and most
importantly while the president often
says that one loss is too many we do we
welcome word that fatalities are
declining precipitously all across the
country in fact yesterday in America
there were just 505 Americans who
succumbed to the corona virus and that
number had not we hadn't seen that
number in daily losses since March the
reality is because of the cooperation
and the compassion of the American
people we're getting there
we're getting there America and mr.
president at your direction we're going
to continue to work closely with States
around the country to expand testing and
resources we're going to continue to
make sure personal protective equipment
flows but finally what we're going to
continue to do is focus on the most
vulnerable even as we begin to see
evidence that we are starting to put
this coronavirus epidemic in the past
all the more we are going to continue
to to surge the resources and surge the
kind of testing and partnership with
states and health care providers to
ensure that our seniors and anyone with
an underlying immune deficiency anyone
that's vulnerable to the corona virus is
immediately identified and and protected
by every measure that's possible so mr.
president I thank you for the
opportunity we heard great enthusiasm
from governor's all across the country
in both political parties today we're
making great progress I truly do believe
that with the continued partnership that
we have forged with state and local
governments with the tremendous efforts
of our health care workers around
America and with God's help we will
reopen America we will continue to
reopen our country safely and protect
our most vulnerable as we do so Thank
You mr. president you Mike very much and
I think I'll just add on to what Mike
said if we didn't act quickly and
smartly we would have had in my opinion
and in the opinion of others anywhere
from 10 to 20 and maybe even 25 times
the number of deaths we closed the
border to China meaning we put on the
band people coming in from China that
was a very big moment as dr. Fauci said
we saved thousands and thousands of
lives when we did that and that's true
but I think we would have had anywhere
from 10 to 20 or 25 times the number of
deaths if we didn't act the way we did
and also if we didn't act swiftly so if
we're very proud of our team and our
task force and Mike great job Seema
please
good afternoon I want to start with
thanking the one person that's
responsible for today's announcement and
that's President Trump he's been
steadfast in his commitment to lowering
the cost of drugs and protecting the
Medicare program and making sure it
works best for seniors the president
also knows that it's the free market
that leverages competition and
negotiation that that is what can lower
cost and improve quality for the
American patient and because of that
we've been working to slash Medicare's
anti-competitive regulations and it's
worked in the Medicare Part D program as
the president said we are seeing low
premiums a seven year low and in the
Medicare Advantage program we're seeing
a 13 year low in premiums so we're
putting money back in the pockets of
seniors and that means three billion
dollars in savings for patients and six
billion dollars in savings for taxpayers
in an absence of a congressional
solution we applied those same
principles to lowering the cost of
insulin we are waiving Obama care laws
that disincentivize plans from lowering
cost sharing for Medicare beneficiaries
and this is important because we know
that beneficiaries struggle to pay their
insulin costs its patients like Cindy
from Rochester New York she told us that
the high cost of insulin has impacted
her health and that she's been forced to
ration her insulin she said I know that
it's not good at all for my health and
I'm sure that I've affected some organs
negatively because of that lack of money
to purchase insulin but no longer thanks
to the president's leadership Medicare
seniors will pay no more than $35 for
their insulin and that's per month and
that's for all forms of insulin through
all phases of the Medicare Part D
program I also will say that some plans
are free to even go below the 35 dollars
and so they could even see lower
premiums as well
I'm also proud to say that we have over
88 health plans that are participating
in this model and that represents over
1,750 plans that will offer this
low-cost insulin these plans will be
available during this year's open
enrollment which starts in October and I
want to thank the manufacturers and the
health plans for stepping up to the
plate for coming together to negotiate
this great senior savings model it's
going to make such a difference to the
lives of many seniors across the country
and I am optimistic that this could be a
model to lower the costs of many other
drugs in the Medicare program and thank
you again President Trump for bringing
lower-cost priced insulin our seniors
are going to be saving an average of 66
percent in their insulin cost and this
is nothing short of a godsend and with
that I think we're going to hear for one
of our Medicare beneficiaries thank you
thank you so much hi my name's Ellen
field I'm 68 years old and I rely on
Medicare Part D I've been a diabetic for
over ten years and during that time I've
watched insulin prices rise dramatically
I paid $400 a month now for a salon
I appreciate President Trump putting a
policy place that will help people like
myself for the future as far as insulin
products thank you that's very nice and
many many people feel the same way they
can't actually believe it $35 and less
and less and they were being ripped off
at a level that nobody's seen before but
that's true with a lot of other things
and we're taking care of them too
so I want to thank everybody for being
here in particular of these great
executives thank you very much thank you
very much you were very impressive in
your speech by the way thank you very
much John plays mr. president can you
tell us what you plan to do regarding
sanctions against China for its pending
actions against Hong Kong and do you
also intend to
put restrictions on F and J visas for
students and researchers coming into the
United States from China your questions
early we're doing it now we're doing
something now I think you'll find it
very interesting but I won't be talking
about it today I'll be talking about it
over the next couple of days yeah okay
but it's a very important question yes
please anybody yeah please mr. president
two questions about a couple of things
you've tweeted about in the last few
days were you meaning to criticize Vice
President Biden for wearing a mask
yesterday and can you explain why you've
been tweeting about a conspiracy theory
that has been proven to not be true no
Biden can wear a mask but he was
standing outside with his wife perfect
conditions perfect weather
they're inside they don't wear masks and
so I thought it was very unusual that he
had one on but I thought that was fine I
wasn't criticizing him at all why would
I ever do a thing like that
and your second question was I couldn't
hear you
the second can you take it up because I
cannot hear I'll just speak louder sir
okay good you want to be politically
correct go ahead no sir I just want to
wear the mask the second question was
about your tweets about the woman who
died who you're suggesting that Joe
Scarborough was responsible yeah a lot
of people suggest that and hopefully
someday people are going to find out
certainly a very suspicious situation
very sad very sad and very suspicious
question please ask you not to Twitter
tweet have you seen the letter that was
written by her husband begging Twitter
to delete your tweets talking about how
hard it's been for his family for him
but I'm sure that ultimately they want
to get to the bottom of it and it's a
very serious situation I also saw a clip
with with Joe and Imus where they were
having a lot of fun at her expense and I
thought it was totally inappropriate now
it's a very suspicious thing and I hope
somebody gets to the bottom of it it'll
be a very good thing as you know there's
no statute of limitations so it would be
a very good very good thing to do okay
who's next any questions or an insulin
yeah please mr. president there
a bill in Congress that would that's
related to the weekers it passed the
Senate it's gonna be up in the house are
you are you willing to sign that would
take you to look at it very strongly
they got a report this afternoon I'll be
looking at it this afternoon special
that you mentioned on China
does that include sanctions it's
something you're gonna be hearing about
over the next before the end of the week
very powerfully I think yeah please yeah
is there any reason why someone who does
not have diabetes would take insulin is
there any sort of medical reason for
that I could ask that question to
anybody like to discuss that do you want
to discuss it please go ahead do you
know the answer either one of you or
both come on let's get these highly paid
executives up here to give the answer
Seema
please Jerome we picked a good one we
got it right well thank you mr. pregnant
I think it's important for everyone to
know that as Tracy Brown highlighted
earlier one in three Americans is
actually either diabetic or pre-diabetic
and I would encourage folks to go to
Diabetes org slash risk the risk - test
so diabetes org slash risk - test to
find out if you are at risk for diabetes
as far as insulin goes we know that
again 7 million people actually are
dependent on insulin we know that from a
type 1 diabetes standpoint 1.6 million
Americans have type 1 diabetes and most
all of them are dependent on insulin
your body mister president actually
makes insulin endogenously and people
such as you and I we make our own
insulin so yes we do utilize insulin but
we make it ourselves now other people
who have diabetes often times need
exogenously made by many of these great
manufacturers here so that they can be
healthy and live long and successful
lives and make no mistake about it if
they can get affordable insulin they can
live a long and healthy life and that's
what we're here for today today is a
very important day
it is a monumental day because Tracy
we've been working for years to try to
address the price of insulin for years
this is an important day and I want to
thank you mr. president I want to thank
all the people here from making that
insulin affordable to more people thank
you very much and Tracy do you agree
with it and the question I found to be a
very interesting one but is that an
unusual question or an unusual
circumstance
right okay good I thought it was a very
good question actually please good Thank
You mr. president we see in Europe
slowly from one country to the other
they are opening their borders and
letting people going from moving from
one country to the other
are you considering for the good of the
US economy are you considering lifting
the flight ban from Europe in the next
weeks well we're just putting a ban on
as you know going on immediately
essentially almost immediately to Brazil
and from Brazil into our country so from
Brazil to the United States to having a
very hard time in Brazil we'll be doing
certain announcements on other countries
including Europe as we move along and
where they're making progress we'll
start to open it up but only where
they're making progress they're making
some good progress I think we're making
very good progress we're making very
good progress on the economy the numbers
are better than anybody would have
anticipated and certainly I think that's
been reflected in the stock market which
had a very big day and it's over 25,000
and when you think 25,000 is a very high
number when you think that it was at
29,000 and now it's a 25 that's a very
big day it's up very substantially over
the last six months so we had a very big
day but people are seeing what's
happening they're seeing there is a
pent-up demand as I was predicting and
you're gonna see it more and more we
call it the transition to greatness and
it really is we're gonna have a third
quarter that's going to be good we're
gonna have a fourth quarter that has the
potential to be really good and we're
gonna have the best year one of the best
years we've ever had next year that's
what we see yeah John go ahead mr.
president is it your intention to bring
American forces home from Afghanistan by
Thanksgiving Day and is the Pentagon
drawing up plans to that effect well I
think everyone knows we're down to less
than 8,000 troops we're with
leadership in many different fields and
in many different parts of of that
country we're with we're dealing with
the Taliban we're dealing with the
president the president now has gotten
themselves straightened out with the two
presidents but we're dealing with
because they had as you know they had
competing factors and factions yeah I
think we want to get where they're 19
years we're really not acting as
soldiers were acting as police and we're
not sent over there to be policemen but
were there 19 years and yeah I think
that's enough and they understand we're
having very positive talks we want to
bring our soldiers back home we want to
bring them back home and we're not only
talking about their we're talking about
other countries also we bring our
soldiers back home we can always go back
if we have to we have to go back we'll
go back and we'll go back raging and
then we'll go back as warriors fighters
but right now we're policing and we're
not meant to be a police force we're
meant to be a fighting force it's
Thanksgiving Day the target no I have no
target but as soon as reasonable over a
period of time but as soon as racism
we're down to 7,000 some odd soldiers
right now and in Iraq were down to 4,000
soldiers so we're making a lot of
progress in Syria you remember John on
the border when I took the soldiers out
of the border everyone said oh that's so
terrible well I spoke to President
Erdogan yesterday of Turkey the borders
been fined without us they've been
policing that border for 2,000 years all
of a sudden we had thousands of soldiers
there doing their work for what
guarding Syria and Turkey on a border a
very long border now we want our troops
back home we took them out that was a
year ago I was criticized nothing
happened except they're watching their
own borders now we kept the oil but at
some point we'll take care of the Kurds
with respect to the oil and get out yeah
please go ahead mr. president quickly on
your meeting with Governor Cuomo
tomorrow yeah he's coming in can you say
what you're going to be discussing do
you have a particular agenda do you
think he'll discuss the Gateway project
that the the Hudson River
I would imagine we would but he
he has for the meeting so we'll see what
he wants but he has for the meeting
Governor Cuomo and will be coming in
sometime tomorrow
yeah please good what can he tell us
about the documents reportedly
Declassified by Rick Grinnell just
before he stepped down as DNI are you
prepared to release the transcripts of
the Flynn kizlet conversations yeah I'd
like to hear it too I mean I'd like to
hear the FBI as you know said that he
didn't lie
and certainly the conversation almost
regardless it was a good conversation he
was allowed to do it and the Muller
people who are have been proven very bad
very bad things they did very bad thing
a lot of bad things are being found out
about the hoax greatest hoax in the
history of our country and it was an
illegal hoax and a very dangerous hoax
and a lot of bad things have been found
out about Muller and the gang so I would
like to hear that conversation yeah I
would like to hear it personally so
whatever they want me to do I'll do I
think Rick Grinnell has done an
incredible job and things are happening
now that I always do this was the answer
this was a a an attempted coup by a
bunch of dirty cops and others these are
dirty cops dishonest slime bags all
right yeah question go ahead Jeff thank
you sir mr. president on Friday you
announced that you wanted governor's to
reopen churches and synagogues and
mosques and you said you would overrule
them if they if they declined to do so
can you explain what authority you had
in mind when you said that you would do
that I can absolutely do it if I want to
and I don't think I'm gonna have to
because it's starting to open up we need
our churches and our synagogues and our
mosques we want them open churches
synagogues mosques and other we want
them open and we want them open as soon
as possible now I can tell you I know a
lot of pastors a lot of rabbis Imams and
they they want to take care of their
people they want to take care they don't
want anyone getting hurt or sick and
they're going to take care of their
people we need we need these people we
need we need people that are going to be
leading us in faith that we're
opening them up and if I have to I will
override any governor that wants to play
games if they want to play games that's
okay but we will win and we have many
different ways where I can override them
and if I have to I'll do that but we
want our churches and our synagogues and
our mosques etc we want them open now
there may be some areas by the way where
the pastor or whoever may feel that it's
not quite ready and that's okay that's
okay but let that be the choice of the
congregation and the pastor John go
ahead mr. president how long will you
give North Carolina Governor Roy Cooper
to provide you with the information that
you and the RNC are asking for before
you decide to look elsewhere for a venue
for the RNC convention in August well as
you know we don't have much time because
we have to know that if we're going to
spend millions of dollars on an arena we
want to be in North Carolina I love
North Carolina one North Carolina we
just had a big two races that we won
recently for Congress in North Carolina
two very big races that the press didn't
want a report on if we were to lost them
it would have been the biggest story in
political history but we just won two
races it's a very important place to me
I love North Carolina in fact my son
Erik and Laura named a baby Carolina and
came from I think both but she was born
in North Carolina as you know Laura so
it's a very important place to me but at
the same time and I think the people
understand this we have a governor that
doesn't want to open up the state and we
have a date of August in the end of
August and we have to know before we
spend millions and millions of dollars
on an arena to make it magnificent for
the convention and we have tremendous
people I mean economic development
consequences are tremendous for the
state we have to know that when the
people come down they're going to have
the doors open now if the governor can't
tell us very soon unfortunately we'll
have no choice this is nothing to do
with us this is between the governor and
North Carolina and the people of North
Carolina but the people want it and
we'll have to see whether
the governor he's a Democrat and a lot
of the Democrats for political reasons
don't want to open up their states so
we'll see if that works but I don't
think it will I'd love to have it in
North Carolina that was why I chose at
Charlotte but we're gonna see we're
gonna see and at the end we need a fast
decision from the governor he's gonna
have to because he's been acting very
very slowly and very suspiciously but
we'll find out a question place what's
it so in terms of soon are we talking a
week what we need yeah I mean we can't
take we're talking about a very short
period of time
it's a massive expenditure and we have
to know yeah I would say within a week
that certainly we have to know now if he
can't do it if he feels that he's not
going to do it all he has to do is tell
us and then we'll have to pick another
location and I will tell you a lot of
locations want it but I picked North
Carolina because I do love that state
and it would have been a perfect place
for it and it still would be but he's
got to say that you know when thousands
of people come to the arena that they'll
be able to get in does that make sense I
mean you know we'll spend millions and
millions of dollars on this magnificent
design but in the end they have to be
able to get in I don't want to have it
where we get there and then they
announce after all the money was spent
all the work was done all the people
travel in guess what you can't put
anybody in the arena or you can put a
tiny number of people in the arena we
can't do that John yeah please go ahead
there are now more than still more than
a dozen states in this country where
case numbers are rising so why is it
suspicious if a governor says look we
don't want to move that that quickly we
still think we need to shut down oh I
think it's fine they have to do it look
the governor's in certain ways have to
do what they want to do but they have to
tell me what they're doing and when it
comes to churches etc they will be
overridden by me when it comes to other
things and you know many other things
they won't if I think some things being
done incorrectly or wrong I'm going to
do it but you have different governors
and they have very different views on
where they are and where they're going
so we'll see what happens please go
ahead sir I'm sure you saw the images
from over the weekend of people out on
Memorial Day weekend they were crowding
pools crowding boardwalks do you have
any message
those people yeah always be safe you
want to be safe we're opening up but you
want to be safe go ahead please thank
you
about mail-in voting you've been you've
been speaking out against a lot against
that of mail-in voting yeah you'll be
speaking a lot about that what why
should somebody who is afraid of getting
coronavirus going to public places
standing in a line etc why should they
no why should they not be allowed to to
mail in well that's gonna be in a long
time from now number one you know it's
quite a ways away number one but when
you do were all mail-in voting ballots
you're asking for fraud people steal
them out of mail boxes people print them
and then they sign them and they give
them in that the people don't even know
where they're double-counted people take
them away they force people to vote they
harvest you know what harvesting is they
take many many ballots and they put them
all together and then they just dump
them and nobody has any idea whether
they're crooked or not look you do
mail-in voting now it's another thing to
do absentee voting or if somebody has a
medical condition where they go through
a process and they get an absentee
ballot that's okay that's different but
in California the governor sent I hear
Ora sending millions of ballots all over
the state millions to anybody to anybody
people that aren't citizens illegals
anybody that walks in California is
going to get a ballot we're not going to
destroy this country by allowing things
like that to happen we're not destroying
our country this has more to do with
fairness and honesty and really our
country itself because when that starts
happening you don't have a fair if you
have a rigged system you have a rigged
system and that's what would happen
so mail-in ballots and the governor of
California did better than any that I
could ever do in terms of explaining
when he sent out or will send out and I
don't know I think it's maybe partially
already done millions and millions of
ballots to anybody in California that's
walking or breathing many of those
people don't have the right to vote well
they'll be voting and you know what
we're not going to let it happen because
you subvert
our process and you're making our
country a joke and the Democrats are
doing it because in theory it's good for
them although last week we won two big
races we won in Wisconsin and won in
California California 25 we won a
tremendous race in California that was I
was interested because at the end of the
race they brought in the Democrats
Democrat governor same governor he
brought in voting booths not mail-in
voting booths because they were losing
they saw that through the ballots but no
you can't do that you can't do the
mail-in ballots because you can have
tremendous fraud and remember what I
said they'll be grabbing them from mail
boxes they'll even be printing them
they'll use the same paper the same
machines and they'll be printing ballots
illegally and they'll be sending them in
by the hundreds of thousands and
nobody's going to know the difference we
can't do that you want to vote you
really have to absentee is okay you're
sick you're way as an example I have to
do an absentee because I'm voting in
Florida and I happened to be president
and I live in that very beautiful house
over there that's painted white so
that's okay and it's okay for people
that are sick and they can't get up
something you know something but voting
is a great honor it's a great honor and
people love to go out and vote and I
want to keep it that way and if we don't
keep it that way we'll have nothing but
a rigged system in this country we can't
do that thank you very much everybody
thank you
yeah I was trying to advertise him for
the guy on TV
you
you